um hi i wanted to come on here
and just talk to y'all for a second say
hi say what's up
say thank you we have been happy in this
land for
a minute now and now that i just got to
share that with the world
it just it's awesome
after days of dropping hints jojo siwa
is opening up about her sexuality and
maybe the caption to this emotional
video post
says it all happy girl so so happy
but like personally i
have never ever ever
been this happy before and it feels
really awesome
and i've been happy for a little bit now
and it's just
so so so
awesome and i just
the 17 year old social media star took
to instagram on saturday
thanking all of her fans for their
support after coming out as a member
of the lgbtq plus community thank you
because for the last what would it be
now 48 hours
72 hours i have gotten
the most endless amount of love and
support and it
is but i right now what matters
is that you guys know that no matter who
you love
that it's okay and that it's awesome and
that the world is there for you there's
so many people
that are there for you but she says for
right now
she's not putting a label on anything
somebody asked somebody said
what label are you um you know
i have thought about this and the reason
why i'm not ready to say this answer is
because i don't
really know this answer um and
i you know wanna i wanna i wanna share
everything with the world i really do
but i also want to keep
things in my life private until they're
ready to be public this
outpouring of support began last week
right after jojo's post on social media
that hinted at her personal revelation
on wednesday jojo appeared in this tick
tock video which included the hashtag
pridehousela and the caption read
now you're one of us jojo later tweeted
a photo of her wearing a
t-shirt that reads quote best gay cousin
ever bella's commenting what's up bella
and jojo celeb pals are sharing their
praise as well
bella thorne commented in her insta
stories congrats
little queen love it loves it loves it i
need
i need to pick it up quicker paris
hilton reposted jojo's photo
with a cute animation that reads love
is love adam rippon tweeted quote
wow we love you are you excited to meet
emily
and jojo's former dance coach abby lee
miller
took to instagram with some throwback
pics
she wrote in the caption quote i always
knew
the world would be a more colorful
positive
sparkly place with a kind loving
dazzling triple threat like you in it
jojo opened up to e.t in december about
her plans to focus
more on her career than relationships in
the next year
will you date again anytime soon you
know my manager actually asked me the
same question she said so now what like
are you gonna get to another
relationship
and actually everyone's asked me that
and my
thing is is my life is so figured out
like i
you know i don't go to school like i
don't have to study for tests right now
i don't
my career is so like boom this is what's
happening and i just have to keep
running forward on that track and so for
me
on the relationship side of things it's
more just like a fun thing
and and you know if it comes around
great
and if it doesn't come around also great
like i have so much that i'm doing right
now
that it's like all right like if anyone
wants to join the party like i'm down
but if nobody wants to join the party
all right cool like you know